- Montfort, fermez jamais!
- Ces trois mots, prononcés
il y a 25 ans, seront à jamais
gravés dans l'histoire
des Franco-Ontariens.
Un cri du coeur lancé lors
d'un grand rassemblement
en mars 1997, qui a eu l'effet
d'un électrochoc.
(applaudissements)
JEAN-MARC LALONDE, ancien maire
Rockland, ancien député libéral
- On n'oubliera jamais.
Fermer Montfort, jamais.
C'est elle.
- Ce jour-là, Gisèle Lalonde
est devenue le fer de lance
de la bataille con
le gouvernement conservateur
de Mike Harris, qui menaçait
de fermer l'hôpital Montfort,
le seul hôpital de langue
française de l'Ontario.
Une bataille qui prendra fin
par une victoire historique
en cour d'appel.
GÉRALD SAVOIE, ancien PDG,
Hôpital Montfort
- La francophonie ontarienne
aujourd'hui jouit d'une
protection constitutionnelle.
On a droit a toutes les
institutions auxquelles nous
avons de besoin, non seulement
pour survivre, mais pour
s'épanouir. Le dossier Montfort,
puis le fameux principe
Montfort, c'est un des plus
gros, sinon le plus gros
changement consitutionnel
dans l'histoire du Canada.
C'est Gisèle Lalonde ça.
LUCILLE COLLARD, députée, Parti
libéral de l'Ontario
- Le grand héritage qu'elle nous
laisse, c'est vraiment de nous
dire : "Çututut la peine
de se battre."
- On n'apprendra jamais.
- Gisèle Lalonde a d'abord fait
carrière dans l'enseignement,
avant de s'impliquer au sein
de nombreux organismes franco-
ontariens.
Après avoir tenté sa chance
p p politique provinciale,
elle devient mairesse de Vanier
en 1985. Et là aussi elle a
livré bataille, notamment
contre les fusions municipales.
GUY COUSINEAU
ancien maire de Vanier
- Je me rappelle d'une phrase
qu'elle avait mentionné :
"Ne touchez pas a Vanier."
Alors qu'on parlait de réforme.
Elle était droite Mme Lalonde,
elle donnait sa pensée
et c'était vraimvévévéritable.
- Gisèle Lalonde était avant
tout une mère de famille,
celle de trois enfants, qui ont
dû partager leur mère avec toute
une communauté.
GUY LALONDE
fils de Gisèle Lalonde
- C'est certain que c'était
diililile. En même temps on
savait qu'on était privilégiés.
On réalisait l'absence de maman,
mais sans trop savoir... sans
trop connaître l'ampleur de son
implication. Alors quand on
rencontre des gens comme ça,
qui nous reconnaissent ou nous
rappelle ou encore aujourd'hui,
qui  t t téléphonent, c'est
toujours très touchant de savoir
qu'elle a eu un si grand impact.
- Gisèle Lalonde s'est éteinte
à l'âge de 89 ans, à l'hôpital
qu'elle a tant aimé et défendu.
BERNARD LEDUC, PDG,
Hôpital Montfort
- Il y a beaucoup d'émotions
présentement. Les gens étaient
tres attachés a Gisèle, donc
pour l'instant c'est vraiment un
deuil collectif qu'on ressent.
- Après l'annonce de son décès
plusieurs citoyens se sont
rendus tout naturellement
devant l'hôpital.
- Son implication, le mouvttt
SOS Montfort a fait en sorte
que bien partout au Canada,
on parlait des Franco-Ontariens
et ils savaient qu'on existait.
- Elle a vraiment un bon impact
sur plusieurs francophones,
elle a montré la langue.
- Ils se sont battus, on s'est
battu, puiesesest donné quelque
chose, faut continuer.
- Pour la famille de Gisèle
Lalonde c'est un moment
de tristesse, mais aussi
de solidarité.
- Peut-être qu'aujourd'hui avec
son décès, j'ose espérer que
c'est peut-être encore
aujourd'hui un moment,
une occasion de ralliement,
pour nos rappeler l'importance
de l'engagement.
- Ici alalalie Tremblay,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.